bonjour jean vincent brisset merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france la chine riposte donc contre
les états unis en adoptant cette loi
mais appelle en même temps à
l'apaisement et à la discussion
comment va réagir joe biden selon vous
depuis l'angleterre
je pense que je veux pas que tu as
continué à affirmer une parc j'ai
sanctions qu'il a déjà prises un qui
sont dans la suite des sanctions qui ont
été prises par son prédécesseur seront
maintenus à l'exception d'un sa tempe
choses comme les réseaux petit of the
witch at 1 pour lequel la suspension va
être réexaminée un autre part les
négociations sur les accords commerciaux
entre la chine et les états unis vont
être poursuivies pour le moment mais ce
qui est intéressant dans cette fois
c'est qu'on retombe sur des des choses
qu'on a connu il ya trente ans des lois
des sanctions contre des sanctions
donc des lois de rétorsion qui sont
assez bizarres
d'autant plus que les termes ne sont pas
publiés on a des lois on pourra brandir
sachant qu'on ne sait pas quel est le
texte de la loi au départ vous venez de
parler du prédécesseur de joe biden
s'était donald trump évidemment les
relations chine etats unis se sont
dégradés sous son mandat
comment expliquer que joe biden ne se
différencie pas de son prédécesseur sur
ce point aussi un consensus dans la
population américaine est de la chine
d'un côté des gens qui est dur vis à vis
de la chine pour des raisons
humanitaires
d'autres qui sont dures vis-à-vis de la
chine pour des raisons de souveraineté
et d'économie
et tout ça ça fait une majorité
nationale ou pour la campagne électorale
s'était pas le seul point de convergence
entre les deux candidats la loi contre
les sanctions étrangères adoptées par la
chine est ce qu'elle peut réellement
dissuader les pays qui on avait
l'intention de sanctionner payant à
partir du moment où on sait que les lois
ne pensais pas du tout quel est son
contenu comment ils pourraient être
appliquées et quelles en sont les
conséquences
c'est une dissuasion a priori à l'heure
actuelle c'est une pigne est en train de
durcir sa position sur un peu tous les
sujets est ce qu'on aura des premières
réaction autre bout de cette loi des
sanctions contre les entreprises pour
que des personnalités il y en a déjà eu
auprès des personnes militaires
occidentales pas seulement américaine et
stoner a plus ou non de ces sanctions
est ce que les communiqués qui sont de
plus en plus nombreux ces débours des
persécutions des mi lourds ont suscité
des réactions passe quelque chose
les etats-unis comme l'union européenne
accuse la chine de violations des droits
de l'homme notamment vous ne parlez des
ouïes cours accuse aussi la chine de vol
de propriété intellectuelle
accusations fondées ou simple
jeu diplomatique selon vous dans ces
accusations sont tout à fait fondée
aussi bien les atteintes aux droits de
l'homme pas seulement les bourgs comme
vous dites et les accumulations au
niveau de la propriété intellectuelle et
industrielle
ça c'est un grand classique et ça
continue il faut voir aussi que la chine
à l'heure actuelle de nouveau un millier
rose qui s'approche
c'est celle des jeux olympiques d'hiver
de pékin il commence à y avoir des
menaces de boycott et ça c'est quelque
chose que la chine a beaucoup de mal à
supporter une unité de contre l unité
multilatéral contraire c'est quelque
chose qui est très très difficile avec
les chinois wang pas mal à gérer on se
souvient d'ailleurs en 2008 quand
quelqu'un veut organiser les jeux
n'étaient y avait déjà eu un appel au
boycott
quelle solution pourrait permettre
d'apaiser les tensions selon vous entre
washington et pékin
alors pour le moment ces tensions
washington en a besoin parce que ça
permet de justifier les conséquences de
tout ce qui re localisation et il
revient de souveraineté donc j'imagine
papé tensions vont brutalement s'arrêter
d'un autre côté c'est une ping a choisi
de d'affiché de s'afficher très
nationaliste mais beaucoup à l'intérieur
de son propre pays et aussi bien les
états unis que la chine ont des
dirigeants qui sont surtout préoccupés
de leur politique intérieure et des
repos la politique extérieure c'est
plutôt de retomber d'un va faire la
politique intérieure donc l'un comme
l'autre sont un peu coincé dans les
positions dures pour le moment et
quelques sa ferme la chine les etats
unis je pense que pour le moment c'est
la chine qui a à perdre parce que les
états unis ont une capacité intérieure
totale à d'autarcie enfin presque quand
même relativement importantes et à des
moyens de dirt supplée à la chine pour
beaucoup de choses dans quatre usines du
monde la chine a beaucoup plus besoin de
son principal client et a besoin de
clients occidentaux 6 2 une partie de
l'occident celui d'une certaine manière
contre la chine c'est la chine qui
effectivement est en difficulté
merci jean vincent brisset d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste de la chine est
chercheur associé à l'iris